GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JANUARY
TWENTY EIGHTH IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER PLEASE BE ADVISED ON
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS BE MADE
AS ALSO BEING TELEVISED SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
HERE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO HERE
DEEP HERE FLORA HERE GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE WORKS OVER
HERE FROM US HERE REASSURED
WORKS HERE HAPPENS HERE WE
HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE
CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR MOTION
ON THE CONSENT -- MOVE ON THIS
IS CHRIS SECONDED BY MISTER
GRAYSON -- BETTER SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLING HIGH
FULLY AYE CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
CARILLO ID FIVE DAY BY FLORA
FLORA AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE KAMLAGER-DOVE
AYE AYE QUIRK SILVA AYE QUIRK
SILVA AYE A PROMOTIONAL HAD
FROM MOST I READ THIS RIVERSIDE
WORKS FINE WORKS AYE MATHIS
MOUNTAINSIDE BURGER THE
OCEANS PASSED AND THIS RULES
COMMITTEE IS IT CAN BE VERY